I think a big part of the move for 2024
internally will be people continuing to
coach and up scill their team not just
on their BD approach but also in their
pitching ability making sure that we
don't end up in this almost reverse
bubble where the market flips back to
candidate sourcing and people have
forgotten how to engage candidates
properly right like it's almost this
like weird this weird Matrix but I think
the big one will actually be offline
events really in a market where everyone
is trying their best to engage with
people and trying to stand out is there
anything better than being able to
actually meet someone face to face
whether that's at live podcast event or
whether that's for dinner or for coffee
or you know an exclusive Round Table
event or whatever it might be we've seen
massive traction this year by you know
meeting people offline and certainly
from what we're hearing from the clients
that we work with like you know not
finding it as tough as the others as
they've doubled down on making sure that
their business development approach
isn't just to Simply get a meeting to
win a job it's to it's to you know
create an offline relationship